One of the things we consistently talk
about here at the Rubin report is why
it's important to judge people as
individuals and not as a collective.
You as an individual are much more than
your immutable characteristics be at
your skin color,
your religion or your sexuality to judge
you on those characteristics is actually
what the essence of prejudice really is.
Prejudice of course means to prejudge,
so if you look at a black person or a
Muslim person or a gay person and think
that you know what they think,
or more importantly how they should
think based on those characteristics,
then you are actually the one who's
being prejudiced.
Sadly,
many of the people who accuse others of
bigotry and racism these days are often
the people who practice this brand of
prejudice the most without even
realizing that they're doing so.
Just look at some of the things that my
friends Larry elder,
my [inaudible] and Ion Hirsi Ali or
called by the so called tolerance side.
When you look at a group of people and
you think you know what they should
think or what's best for them based on
those outward characteristics and now
what's going on in their own minds.
You not only lock people into your
preconceived notions of what they are,
but stifle the voices of the minorities
within these minorities.
This is why the voices of black
conservatives and gay Muslims,
for example,
are so relevant and interesting today.
If you really listen to these minorities
within the minorities,
you will judge these people on their
thoughts,
their logic,
and their reason instead of simply how
they look or who they love.
In a way,
the very existence of BS freethinkers
within these minority communities,
flips identity politics on its head,
showing the flaws of this postmodern
intersectional way of thinking.
Just see how quickly those who preach
identity politics turn on black or
Latino people who have conservative
political beliefs or how easily they
dismiss gays are women who dare talk
about how poorly they're treated in
Islamic societies.
Identity.
Politics only works if you believe that
the most important quality about each of
us are the attributes which we are born
with thus cannot change rather than the
ideas which we come to learn.
I view this twisted ideology as a true
existential danger for the tolerant and
Liberal,
albeit flawed country that America is
Martin Luther King,
Jr's desire for his children to be
judged by the content of their character
and not the color of their skin is being
undermined by the very people who
purport to be the tolerant ones.
We're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty today and joining me is
the CEO of the Thurgood Marshall College
Fund,
Johnny c Dot Taylor.
The organization represents nearly
300,000
students who attend the 47 historical
black colleges in America today.
I heard Johnny speak at an event in
Dallas a couple months ago and was blown
away by his passion,
his commitment to educating young people
and his desire to move past identity
politics.
We're going to talk about politics,
race,
and much.
Has
the role of the Black College changed as
we've become a more fair injustice
society.
That's just one of the many questions
I'll ask johnny and I'll only judge him
by the content of his answers,
not the color of his skin.
We're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty today and joining me is
the president and CEO of the Thurgood
Marshall Scholarship Fund,
but the only national organization
representing the nearly 300,000
students attending America's 47
historically black colleges.
Johnny c Dot Taylor.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
So glad to be here.
I gotta tell you man,
I and I just did tell you,
but now I'll repeat it.
Since the cameras are on you.
We've been doing this thing with learn
liberty for a little over a year or so
and they've sent us some great authors
and professors and thinkers.
I've never requested anyone.
User are the first person I requested
because I saw you speak a couple of
months back at a conference for
academics.
Had to do a lot about free speech and
liberty and all sorts of things and you
gave the keynote address on the final
night and I thought,
this guy is possibly the most passionate
speaker I've ever seen in my life.
Thank you.
Where does that passion come from?
Well,
let's start there.
Before we even talking about what you
do,
just the passion that you had.
I was just like that.
I got to get that guy on the show.
See,
it's interesting.
I spent my career in the entertainment
space,
the media space,
paramount pictures,
spelling,
entertainment,
blockbuster entertainment.
So all of my life was doing that kind of
stuff,
making money,
right?
But I always had this yearning for the
community and how higher education could
play into him.
Sort of fixing what was going on in my
community.
And I say the community,
I mean all of Americans,
but particularly African Americans.
And there were so many conversations
that didn't occur,
weren't allowed to occur.
And so I took this new role at the
Thurgood Marshall College Fund
representing Black Colleges.
I didn't attend a black college.
Um,
I often say I'm a beneficiary of it
because so many of my teachers and
doctors and lawyers did,
but I didn't,
my parents didn't attend a black
college,
but I thought this was such an
opportunity to come in and really begin
to influence how young people are,
our future leaders,
how they think about the world and then
to challenge them.
My legal education by definition sort of
taught me to challenge the status quo,
to be able to argue both sides or in
some instances three sides of any
argument.
And so that's where it came from.
I really,
I,
I don't sleep at night sometimes
thinking about where America is headed
and that's where the passion comes from.
I'm genuinely concerned about where
we're going.
Yeah,
I feel that too.
And we kind of hit that a little bit
before and now we've got to do it all
over right now.
Um,
tell me a little bit more about your
resume before we get to what you've been
doing these last couple of years because
yeah,
you just mentioned some of that stuff.
I mean,
you've got a pretty prime.
Your linkedin has got to be pretty fat,
less on what,
like eight pages that God is good.
But tell a little bit about that because
I
think it does form Sorta,
you know,
how you end up sitting across from me
here.
So I began my career.
Well,
let me back up.
I did the undergraduate work at the
University of Miami.
I'm a born and raised in Florida,
so I'm the.
You got to give him a shout out to my
school.
Um,
in any event.
I finished school,
went to law school in Iowa at Drake
University.
I came back to south Florida to practice
at a big law firm.
Janet Reno was one of my,
was the first female partner.
So I'm dating myself and takes your way
back.
And then began my practice,
sat on a plane one day,
melt,
met A.
I did not know at the time of
billionaire Wayne Highs,
Zynga who had this small little business
called blockbuster that he was building.
I went in as the third lawyer on staff
and literally we went through this huge
acquisition spree and you know,
you remember blockbuster was on every
corner.
It's the biggest so did that.
Viacom bought us,
so I've spent my time as a lawyer,
as an hr executive and then ultimately
once by combat us and worked for sumner
at Viacom,
Sumner Redstone,
and then uh,
my last corporate gig was running a
business,
a subsidiary for Barry Diller in New
York.
So I literally have had all of the back
office functions and then ran frontline
operator running a business for Barry,
came to TMC in 2010 as the CEO.
So you've been doing this for now about
seven years and you're actually about to
shift into something else which will,
which will get to a little later,
but tell me a little bit about what the
scholarship climb to actually does.
What is the purpose?
Because I know a certain amount of
people,
because I know a lot of your thoughts
on,
on the diversity memo and all that
stuff.
It almost sounds counter to what the
Thurgood Marshall Scholarship Fund might
do.
Right?
So the,
the college fund was actually created by
the way we were created as the
Scholarship Fund Thurgood Marshall
Scholarship Fund about a decade ago.
We changed the name to broaden the remit
to the college funds,
so it's Thurgood Marshall College Fund
and we really only do four things
scholarships.
We provide scholarships for the
absolutely most talented students,
so this is not sort of a social services
feel good for kids who didn't get a shot
k through 12.
These are the brightest kids who frankly
just have money problems they need,
so scholarships that are needing and
sort of need and merit based.
Then capacity building.
We've talked with our schools a lot
about.
There was a time when HPC use captive
market.
If you were black and you want to go to
college,
you attended a black college.
Well,
everything changed.
Be careful what you pray for it.
We asked for diversity,
we got it.
We asked her integration,
we got it,
and so now black students have options
and so black colleges,
historically black colleges have got to
step up.
So the second thing is to build their
capacity to be attractive.
The third thing that we do as
governmental affairs,
I mean a lot of abic advocacy and policy
work to make sure that we're not making
emotional decisions.
We want to do what is good for our
communities and what's good for this
country.
Those are really the three things that
we focus on as,
as a fund and that's the work that we do
and the thing that most of the folks
frankly don't realize is historically
black colleges are not ebc.
They're not exclusively black colleges.
In fact,
for currently four of our member schools
are majority white,
really majority white.
So they are still historically black
colleges because the hbcus historically
black,
not necessarily currently blank.
So West Virginia State and Bluefield
State College,
both in West Virginia,
Lincoln University in Missouri,
Kentucky State,
uh,
these are schools that while technically
are not technically are actually hpc use
are,
have more white students than black
students.
And those are some of the things that
people don't understand.
This is not about race per se.
How much battling is there over what it
means to be historically black versus
currently diverse?
Because I would imagine you've got,
you know,
ideas and academics and administrators
who were probably pretty entrenched in
keeping things,
just looking at it by numbers,
not necessarily diversity of thought
that's and all that.
So you must be dealing with that
constant.
Oh,
you have no idea.
That's ugly.
And it's interesting because I'm
surprised,
and I know we'll talk about some of
this,
but I'm surprised at the number you'd
like to think millennials,
you know,
we think millennials and we group them
in and they're open and they're diverse
in there.
Well,
I was surprised we've had some students
really not faculty,
not alumni,
but students,
18 or 19 year olds take great issue with
the fact that the institutions are more
diverse than they were.
They wanted to come to an all black
institution and we get there and realize
that we have international students and
white students and Hispanic students.
They really push back.
So that's been a real surprise to me.
How do you break through that?
Well,
you continue.
First of all,
you explained to them that Hbcu is not
ABC.
Then you start with that and you also
then explain,
I find myself oftentimes when I'm
talking to them saying,
let me just put yourself in this
situation.
So just recently one of our campuses,
one of a group of students were really
upset because in fact it was all over
the national news about students came on
the campus of Howard University wearing
the make America great again.
And I said,
no,
I just wanted the student leaders.
I pulled to the sadness.
I don't want you to just for a second to
ask me,
how do you think this would play out
group of black students right after
Obama elected go visit Liberty
University's campus.
They have on the wonderful Obama tee
shirts where they're proud of this new
president and they were literally run
off of campus.
They were threatened,
they were harassed.
How do you think that will go over?
And so what I find myself doing is she
just literally put yourself in that
situation and tell me why this is that
different.
Um,
and then you get that pause,
that moment.
By the way,
that's what motivates me to do my work
because that's the way you influence the
sort of the narrative and how these
young people think.
You have to just stop and say,
I get how you feel right now emotionally
about this,
but for just a second,
let's flip the script and tell me how
this works.
And you're smart,
you're bright.
Tell me how this works out.
That's really part of what motivates me
to do the work.
Yeah.
And that's what we need more of,
right?
I mean because everybody seems hysterics
hysterical over,
over emotional.
So that's like.
It's like I can understand that if I,
if I was black and I wanted to go to a
historically black college and I got
there and I thought it was going to be
80 percent black and I got there and I
was like,
wait a minute,
I'm,
I'm actually still a minority here.
The emotional part,
I can understand it being like,
this doesn't feel right to me,
but then when you hear that and you go,
well,
things actually are changing.
Integration is this,
this is all good.
This is,
this is the purpose,
the purpose of freedom prayed for it.
I often say,
be careful what you pray for.
This is exactly what we said we wanted,
is the opportunity to choose kind of
what I can tell you.
That's when my great grandparents,
yeah.
In fact,
Thurgood Marshall himself for folks
don't realize this.
Thurgood Marshall didn't choose to go to
Howard University.
Law School,
Thurgood Marshall.
Fact of the matter is applied to the
University of Maryland,
was denied admission to that law school.
Went to Howard because it was the
college for black students and law
schools for black students,
and so you just have to think about it.
He then subsequently brought lawsuits to
actually stop that very thing.
Again,
this was an anti Hbcu.
The message was,
I want to be able to choose irrespective
of my skin color where I go to school,
so all of us should have predicted that
we would be right where we are today.
What I find is the young folks just
don't understand the history and then
the older people refuse to tell.
The honest is,
so what's going on there?
Because I don't believe there is so much
nonsense.
The media is so complicit in this.
Yes.
Um,
I,
I don't,
you know,
and,
and identity politics has become so
rooted in everything that I don't blame
the young people who are misguided.
Yeah.
I want to get through to them and,
and all that.
It's the other people that you're
talking about,
the older people on the academics that
are afraid to speak.
What happened there?
Did you see it change?
I,
I did.
I saw it,
you know,
and,
and where I,
when I was in school,
you were encouraged to be a little bit
of a provocateur.
Always respectfully.
You never.
There was no,
no one wanted you to go out and hurt
someone's feelings.
But we were encouraged in law school for
example,
to look at things from all different
sorts of perspectives.
I was given a case once where you'd have
to represent the plaintiff and then turn
around and go against,
you know,
defend him.
So we've just lost that in education
now.
And then I got to tell you more and
more,
I'm talking to students who say,
you know,
I feel a certain way,
but I know that if I either uttered
those my thoughts even in a question
format in the classroom,
I'd be attacked by from my professor.
It would impact my participation in
class green that Po,
that portion of my grade.
Also.
And more importantly,
what do you say to kids say when they
say that perhaps you're at the wrong
school?
I said,
you got to vote with your feet.
Colleges not about,
it's supposed to be a time to explore
and to grow.
If you already knew what you needed to
know to sort of live in life and be
successful,
then you don't need to spend five or six
years and hundreds of thousands of
dollars.
If you are the same person that you
walked in the door at the end of your
freshman year,
um,
then you were cheated.
And I tell them,
you should challenge the institution to
give you a better education.
And sometimes that the way you get
better is to have to confront ideas that
you don't necessarily embrace.
You don't understand them.
One situation that that sort of comes
up,
and I think it helps my students a lot.
Understand where I come from us.
It's,
you know,
listen,
I was an employment lawyer early in my
career and at that time there was a big
question,
for example,
around whether or not gay,
lesbian sexual orientation was covered
under title seven.
Okay.
Big Question.
Gender and sex was clear if you were
being discriminated against on the basis
of something else.
That on sort of sexual orientation that
wasn't covered.
I actually brought those cases and made
those arguments.
I defended them,
that they,
she was not the intent of the congress
and this was ridiculous,
etc.
That gender is something that's innate.
You're born That way and low gay and
lesbian,
maybe not so much.
Fast forward.
Where are we?
That's 1992.
I think it's important that context.
That's right.
Put it in context.
Now,
fast forward,
you began to evolve and grow.
You start sitting down and getting to
know people who are different than you
are or that your family is or that you,
you,
you just,
you began to evolve and it challenges
your own notions of what is right and
what is wrong and maybe you conclude
there is no right or wrong here.
This is just life that we're evolving as
a human species,
kind of even.
I've had to do that and there are so
many instances of that in my own life,
and so when you begin to have
conversations in the context of the
classroom with students,
you see the growth.
That's the beautY.
That shouldn't be the beauty of it.
Instead,
what I'm seeing more and more,
david is there actually retarding the
growth students.
You're not encouraged to think.
You come in thinking a certain way.
Your professors want you to think a
certain way.
Your institution wants you to think a
certain way,
but here's the problem.
The real problem is then you go to work
and you have to confront the reality of
you know you're not protected in this
bubble.
You've got to live and work next to
people who don't look like you,
and frankly that's a challenge.
That's something that people talk about
a lot.
when I talk about black colleges,
the only.
I don't question the relevancy of hbcs.
I think that's a dumb argument.
It's a dumb question.
There is a fair question that is posed.
If you have gone to a black elementary
school,
middle school,
grew up in a black community and then
you went to a black college.
The first meaningful interaction that
you had with people who are not black is
in the workplace.
You're going to be at a disadvantage
just practically speaking and so you it.
It has some downside,
tons of upside.
By the way,
being a majority and a minority
community.
black colleges give you a very special
and nurturing environment to grow in,
but there's a cost to that.
Yeah.
Is that just the natural evolution of
the way humans are,
that if you have a legit grievance,
you may need a different place.
Or for thurgood marshall who did not get
accepted to the Maryland law school,
so he needed a place to go to completely
legit in that time and place,
but that eventually we,
if a quality works,
because the arc does bend towards
justice,
that eventually you slowly need these
things less.
It doesn't mean that there's no use For
them,
but you.
But a lot of people are sort of addicted
to that original pain or instance or
whatever you want to call it.
You nailed it.
I mean that.
None of us.
It's,
it's,
it's addictive.
I mean,
that's the problem.
And Weaning yourself off of that is
difficult and that's not limited to
black people or any group of people.
It's just that you get used to it.
And this notion that we were to create.
Remember even the concept of affirmative
action was supposed to be remedial.
It was not supposed to go on forever.
Right?
BuT what happens is if you get used to
it and it's a benefit that a new words
to you and people who look like you,
um,
it's really tough to one day say,
okay,
that's done.
I have a seven year old daughter and I,
you know,
there's a point at which she's going to
come off of daddy's credit card and she
was going to fight me if it's 18,
if it's 28 of his 38,
the day that I decide you now have to
leave the nest and figure this out
yourself.
If it's 38,
if I move in with your dog.
Right.
But you're right,
you're onto something that,
that's,
um,
it's even think about just in real life.
that's the thing that I'm intrigued by
is I could not wait until I turned 18.
I could leave my nest and my mama and my
daddy's house and go and start creating
my own.
And I'm seeing some of them for economic
reasons,
but just everyone's sort of staying at
home and they want.
It's a very different world that we live
in right now and I'm intrigued by it.
Yeah.
How much of this also is about the
family in general?
That's one of the things when I've had a
couple,
particularly in this case,
when I've had black conservatives on,
you know,
like larry elder,
talking about the black family you just
mentioned,
you mentioned your mom and your dad,
so I,
I suspect they're still married.
No.
Okay,
so that's interesting.
But they were for obviously most of your
childhood.
Mr.
How much of that structure is related to
all of this?
Why then you can't necessarily deal with
outside influences or or any of that
stuff.
So I struggle with that.
I struggle with that because because of
the realities of slavery,
the black community was always largely
maternally run.
Dad and mom were separated.
Family,
the family unit in the traditional sense
didn't exist so and we were successful
in spite of that.
So I,
I'm noT so sure that I now what I all
day.
I think the value of having mom and dad
in the home and and frankly at some
point grandparents and home to build
that in that I think it's incredibly
important,
but I'm not prepared to say that's why
everything is wrong.
As I pointed out,
my parents ultimately got,
were divorced and all to have two
sisters.
We both went to college.
All three of us rather were successful,
have great lives.
Nobody's been to jail.
No one has eight kids that you know,
so I don't know that I'm Prepared to say
that.
It's totally about
sort of the family unit.
I think family,
the one thing that I'm happy to see now,
his family is being more broadly
defined.
We and our community oftentimes talk
about it takes a village and the family
could be the little old lady cross the
street.
If you don't know your grandmother,
she might essentially become your
grandma in local parentes the concept in
latin that there a whole bunch of folks
who act as parents to make it all
happen.
So I think we have to be a little too
careful and I hear the strict
conservatives.
Well,
it's all of this is because the family
model has degraded as well.
Historically,
I'm not so sure we as a people in
particular ever had that.
That's not real.
Yeah.
I was mentioning to you before it also
that I just went to george washington's
estate and you can go to the slave
quarters and they do a daily memorial
and all that,
and they talk about the men living here.
They're living here.
They sometimes only got it interacts for
for minutes in a day and all sorts of
stuff.
Yeah,
so you know,
sometimes when we have to help people
revisit history sometimes they're like,
oh,
it was great.
Back in the day.
Not exactly.
SpeakiNg of history,
I wasn't planning on going here,
but as long as we're talking about this
list,
what do you make of all the monuments
stuff happening right now?
Because I just read one this week that
at at christ church and I think it's in
alexandria.
They're taking down george the minute I
think it's just a plaque actually,
and I guess there was also a plaque to
robert e dot lee that upset some people,
so they said,
all right,
we're going to take down george
washington's as well,
George Washington,
than there is no doubt he did own
slaves.
He freed as many as he legally could.
When he died,
not all of them more because some of
them were technically,
I think owned by martha or for her or
her family or something like that,
but as I said,
they do a great memorial to them.
These people,
we're all complex.
People who were writing law is to free
people while they own people.
I mean it's a whole freaking thing,
but me personally,
you want my answer firstly because I'm
glad to,
but tell me what do you think?
I don't think you can take these things
down.
I think you can put a,
a,
a counter monument next to them or a
plaque that explains more.
Maybe you could convince me that they
can all be moved to a museum where then
you are going to learn about the
history,
but I'm very leery that there's just no
ending here that we're going to take
down the robert e dot lee stuff.
We're going to take down,
You know,
other confederate stuff,
but he will creep to George Washington.
It will creep to Thomas Jefferson.
I was just at the memorial,
but words that that man wrote about what
freedom is.
That's the stuff we should all care
about and I just feared that there is no
ending here.
I don't know if that's enough of a
justification not to take anything down,
but that's really where my position is
coming from.
That it won't end.
Well,
not surprisingly,
I violently agree with you.
I,
uh,
I would have accepted either.
Oh no,
I know that would've given him,
but frankly,
you know,
there are a couple of aha moments for
me.
First of all,
we don't like to acknowledge this,
but black people owned slaves in America
too.
That's real.
I'm the litmus test is if you own slave
somehow we should erase from history or
puts you into a museum,
a little box so that only
people who visit museums will learn
about.
That's why I don't really like that I
throw it up there because I,
in a q and a that I did at claremont
mckenna,
a kid asked me and I said that.
He said,
well,
what if we put them in mind as I said?
All right.
We can play with that one a little bit,
but to your point,
if you take this to its,
I think illogical in [inaudible] we
didn't go through and parse every
person's history and we find the one
thing they did that we didn't like,
which by the way at that time,
at that point in the world may have been
totally the norm.
I'm not arguing it was good or bad.
I'm just saying it was the way people
lived and it was the what was the more
ready,
the way,
whatever of the time I.
I struggle with this.
I think you put everything into context.
When I ride through and I see a
confederate statue,
I was laughing.
I was in old town alexandria the other
day.
I have passed this particular this.
Which one is it?
I was just as robert e dot lee is the
one that's sitting right in.
It's just passed.
I don't know the street of past king
street.
I think it is.
There's a statute at this guy on a
horse.
I've passed out a number of times and
thought,
well,
that's interesting.
Um,
I've also,
I live in Washington dc on capitol hill
and there are all sorts of these
statutes that frankly charles barkley,
who I don't quote very often to my
impression would it dell,
but he said something which was really
provocative.
he said,
frankly,
most african american people aren't
thinking about that damn monument.
I mean,
it's just,
we have real issues facing our
community.
And the idea that we have now gotten
preoccupied with these monuments is
bizarre to me and frankly and more
disturbing to me is that is divisive.
Anytime you start peeling apart people's
history,
all of this is sort of the history of
the country,
the good and the bad.
And I think that's the beauty of telling
a story.
And when I talk to students about it,
because I've had this conversation with
some of our students and I said,
you know,
all of us,
we go back into history even to find out
that your grandparents weren't perfect
people.
You know,
the grandfather who beat on your
grandmother who cheated on your
grandmother.
The grandmother who,
well,
let's say back in the day,
decided not to have a kid.
just had a kid out of wedlock and decide
to give them to an ant and never
acknowledged and was.
There's so many things we've ball our
bodies and the notion that somehow
you've literally made this person's life
less important because of a decision
that happened.
I mean,
all of us are growing on this journey
called life and I just think we've
gotten too serious about it and it's
also frankly divided the country.
A country that is way too divided right
now.
I mean,
I've never seen.
I think of martin luther king,
a lincoln thurgood marshall.
They have to be like sitting back
somewhere looking at this hand,
oh my god,
I can't believe.
Once we pulled the rules down,
change the laws,
became a more open and free society.
None of us could have thought that this
is where we'd end up.
Yeah,
and you know,
the easy answer is to blame it on trump,
but the fact of the matter is this
started way before.
This has nothing I know so now,
now,
but I'm pretty sure some,
even the.
Even the nfl protests were going on
under obama horse.
When you talk about the historical
stuff,
obama,
his first president,
first four years was against gay
marriage.
now 20 years ago we got to take obama's
statue or take his library down or don't
even start me on that.
I've got countless examples.
You know,
I was talking to folks at a.
That was a big discussion about public
schools and you know,
we need to send all of our kids to
public schools,
synthesize timeout,
timeout,
timeout.
The obama girls were to to go to school
sidwell.
I know it's not very fast for them,
but then you can't turn around and say,
oh,
public school's a wonderful.
They're great for everyone when they
know the reality is they are good enough
for your children.
Those are some of the moments when we
have to stop and just pause and say,
you know this.
It's gotten crazy.
That's the point.
I mean,
I'm so frustrated with it right now
because we're picking apart people's
lives and the reality is none of us
would want someone to do the same thing
on an individual level with me.
you want to pick my life apart.
You can come out and say,
I'm a horrible person.
Ignore the fact that I have a beautiful
seven year old daughter that my parents
were wonderful,
that I'm a good son a good,
but you want to focus on the one or two
decisions that perhaps I would have.
I'm frankly,
I would have done them differently if I
were 48.
I was 18.
So yeah,
it's,
um,
we're just in an interesting spot and I
know that's what you're talking about,
but it disturbs me.
It disturbs me in some very significant
ways that I'm raising a child in this
world,
in this country in particular.
This is not the country I envisioned it
would be.
Yeah.
Do you think there's any chance that it
actually is the country,
but it's just the level of noise has
gotten so out of control.
So when we think about,
you know,
I talk a lot about social media and how
twitter is affecting everybody and the
way we will cater news to ourselves and
all that stuff.
BuT then I took all of august offline.
I shut down.
I was working on my book.
I disappeared for awhile and when I
spent more time just,
I mean I talked to people for a living,
but outside of this room,
just talking to random people,
I think most people do buy everything
that you just said there and I don't
think that people are necessarily as
hysterical as maybe we feel they are.
Do you think that's possible or is that.
I'm just trying to give a real silver
lining to this.
I think you're trying to feel better
because as much as we can,
we can't just put the media over in a
little box.
Particularly.
It used to be traditional media,
but now social media and so when you add
all of that,
it really does influence the narrative
and it influences what people think it
means to live in America and and I do
think we're in a very different place
now and you're right,
every person in the world doesn't know
what's going on.
Manafort gets charged today.
The vast majority of americans don't
know or care.
It's people who watch the news and who
read and who think about this,
who,
and you know,
where it matters.
The vast majority of americans are like,
I'm trying to keep the lights on,
I want to put my kid in school and I
want a decent life and retire with some
decent savings in a bank that's more
practical.
So I think you're right.
But the influencers,
people like me and you,
um,
maybe not like the two of us is the more
liberal media has just put it out there
so far.
Progressively they're really crafting
the narrative and the message and it's,
it's,
it's something that we have to pause.
Do you find yourself with a political
home?
Because obviously I'm in a lockstep with
so much of the things that you're so
many of the things that you're talking
about.
When I heard you give that speech,
I was like,
yeah,
yeah.
Well,
I mean 20 times I was like,
yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah.
Um,
do you,
I mean,
do you consider yourself,
are you in a party or totally
independent?
So or as when I was in North Carolina,
it was called unaffiliated.
That was the phrase you wanted an
independent because there were
independent.
So that was the,
a third party.
So it's unaffiliate.
I was a democrat for years and actually
quite as it's kept up was a big part of
hillary clinton's 2008 campaign,
a raised tons of money.
Had her in my home.
Fundraisers had erskine bowles and his
wife.
I mean I was like really,
really into that world.
I did not see that in the research.
Yeah.
So I'm literally hosted in my home in
North Carolina and did a lot and then
fast forward,
I've become this last election,
frankly less enamored.
So I was not involved in that campaign.
I also wasn't a involved in donald
trump's campaign.
I just have decided that I'm going to
have to figure out where I fit.
And right now it's just,
I'd like to say I'm an american,
I'm a patriot.
I'm trying to figure out on balance
which individual is looking out for the
best interest of America.
And that's a very,
it's a lonely place sometimes.
It's because you know,
we're in this bike,
but you know you are a democrat or a
republican and some call themselves
independents,
but the reality is they lean left or
right.
I'm sort of in the middle.
They were things that I think I would
take positions that I take that are more
conservatively aligned and the near
times when it's more or less
conservatively or more liberally
aligned,
but I don't think you can just fall into
a box.
I really don't.
I think that's the problem.
Frankly.
There are some issues that I really take
a strong position on it.
I mean we were just,
oh,
this is just the other day,
and we'll talk about something.
I was at the advancing justice seminar.
It's advanced justice summit,
which is hosted by the Charles Koch
foundation,
big discussion around reducing the
number of incarcerated americans and so
someone throughout by 20 slash 20,
we want to reduce the number of people
incarcerated by 50 percent.
And I paused and I said,
well,
that's dumb a suppose 30 percent of
those people really should be
incarcerated.
Suppose they're not.
They should.
They absolutely cannot be put back on
the streets.
You're telling me you're thinking
through just someone yells out of your
thinking and I'm thinking it through and
tell you why,
because it bothered me because here's
the deal.
I grew up in one of those fragile
communities.
I grew up and I shared this with the
group.
I said,
I grew up in the area and my
grandmother,
I'll never forget this.
I'll never forget riding up high school.
People would run up to our windows.
She,
you know,
60 plus year old grandmother and me and
an rotc uniform going to highschool drug
dealers run up to our windows.
Prostitutes are standing on the corner
in morning.
This is 7:30,
8:00
in the morning next to a school.
Okay,
but this was the community.
My grandmother one day,
I'll never forget it,
she said they wouldn't allow this in
white town.
They would never put up with this and
white down.
She was so bothered,
so she became committed.
She called demanded police.
She demanded that you remove these
people from our community and so fast
forward you just want to release them
all back to our community,
and I said this to one of the attendees
said,
here's the problem.
That sounds great and it's great for you
because they're not coming back to your
community.
That's that's why this isn't your
problem.
If you release 50 percent of these
people,
where do you think they're coming?
They're not coming into suburbia.
They're going to show back up in the
communities and continue terrorizing and
negatively impacting the community.
So on that plant,
I tell that story to say,
you know,
listen,
I am passionate about and I am bob.
I appreciate well intended people
thinking that just releasing half the
people who are currently incarcerated
into our communities as a good thing,
but they don't think about the impact of
that.
When my kid can't go out and play in the
streets for being shot,
my kid can't.
My daughter has to walk past these
scantily clad women who were selling
themselves and she begins to think
that's normal.
That's not the world,
and you may call that a nonviolent
opened her,
but it's not nonviolent.
It's actually more violent because it's
working into the psyche.
These young people,
uh,
there's so much there because you could
also look at that and go,
well,
a certain amount of those people that
are in there for drug offenses not
selling right.
And,
and if they had had better
representation where more money,
they would have never been in jail in
the first place and either parents or so
you can't just blame the government.
So that's the thing faster.
We want to get to 20 and blame the
system for not giving them good lawyers
and the system for incarcerating them
too long and all of that.
And you forget that a lot of that stuff
started a lot earlier in their lives.
Now you now you took her back to the
conservative point.
That's right.
It's not that scared because by the way,
my only point is it doesn't have to be
mom or dad.
It has to be someone.
It could be a school teacher that helped
infuse morals and the sense of right and
wrong into that kit,
but we've got to go back.
We can't just wake up and say,
okay,
now you've got a 19 year old who has a
long criminal history.
No regard for anyone or anything and say
we just think he or she should not be
incarcerated.
Okay.
Then pray,
tell what are you going to do about
that?
Do you ever get an answer to that?
If you let these people out,
I get that.
I'm totally with you.
Okay.
Came from a bad place.
Didn't have the proper support
potentially in jail for doing drugs,
not even selling them,
so the idea is,
okay,
you want to get this person out of jail.
Even if even if it's just an economic
thing,
you don't want to have the system
spending money on it.
Right,
but now you put them out there,
you still have some responsibility.
I think that the system or whatever you
wanna call it,
has some responsibility to make sure
that now you just don't toss this back
into the mix of what got them there in
the first place and how do you fix that?
That is the big question.
I mean the easy answer is released it
and then what I would say.
And then what,
and the thing that bothers me is that
many of the people who advocate for this
release release,
release don't have to answer the
question what?
Because they have,
they live in neighborhoods with gate
gated neighborhoods with a lot of police
protection,
etc.
So they're not impacted by,
they just want to,
once you get them out and we see this
listen and unfortunately with
individuals who suffer with mental,
a mental illness,
so you,
you want them out and then what,
what,
what are you going to do now?
And that's someone else's problem.
And the system as you call it,
the non system hasn't answered that
question.
All right.
Let's shift a little bit to some
specific issues because I think we've
done a nice little broad job to start
here.
Uh,
you mentioned to me briefly something
about daca that I thought was really
interesting,
how the black community,
you sort of split on this.
Yeah,
yeah.
You know,
daca is on iTs surface.
It's an easy,
it should have been easy,
but what I've come talking about,
the complexity of it and the nuances.
So increasingly our students on hbcu
campuses,
uh,
raising,
they have real beef with this as the way
they described it.
So one of the students put it in it,
it made me pause because I was like,
that's an easy one.
You're noT going to send 12 million
people home.
These kids were brought here by their
parents.
Didn't have a choice.
If I tell my daughter we're going
somewhere,
she's gone.
Right?
So I get it.
Yeah.
And then one of the young women put it
best.
She said,
you know,
think about the chicago.
She said,
the irony of this is that they're very,
the America is all rallying around
providing not only a,
the ability for these students to enroll
in school,
but oftentimes full scholarships for
these students.
The daca students,
while she said,
and here I am,
the legal descendant of slaves,
we were forced to come here and I have
to figure out how to pay for my
education,
and so there's this tension,
there's real tension and they have to
whisper it.
So I asked her,
I said,
well,
why don't you just talk about that in
class?
And she said,
oh,
I will be killed.
that you can't talk about that in class.
She said,
but there's an underground sort of
conversation about that doesn't seem
fair.
If America has enough money to provide
additional scholarship assistance to
students,
then shouldn't you take care of people
like us who were brought here are
parents who were brought here and we
truly are.
And so I was like,
wow,
that's really.
It was a really.
I hadn't thought about it.
It made me pause.
there is also a recent article,
I think it's the chicago times where a
guy wrote an editorial about rahm
emanuel wants to spend one or
$2,000,000,
so I'm providing ids for undocumented
immigrants and the black alderman had a
melt down.
I mean literally it's quoted all over
the papers saying thIs is absurd and
enough's enough.
We have americans here,
americans in chicago who need x,
y and z and instead you want to go spend
a bit.
So there's a tension.
Americans that are really inflection
point that's just not black and white or
conservative and liberal.
There's tension now amongst people of
color.
Yeah.
And it seems to me that obviously that
conversation is good and it's nice to
hear that a student said something to
you that made you reevaluate because
that shows you practice what you preach
obviously.
Um,
is there,
who's the leaDer right now?
If I,
I,
you know,
I know you probably get this one all the
time and I don't even like the question
in a certain way,
but,
but who should black America,
whatever that is.
It's so,
it's so stupid talking about that stuff.
But like who should be in your opinion,
should the community be turning to,
to make some sense of this?
Because there's the usual cast of
characters and we can name all the ones
that you don't like that or on msnbc
everyday and I don't like him either,
so let's just forget those.
Some people that we should be looking at
that and I don't even mean just black
America,
but no for people that really care about
freedom.
So you make the good point.
Um,
I don't even know.
America generally,
you know,
that we can identify someone who is sane
and rational and logical and thoughtful.
But in the african american community,
you've nailed it.
I,
we had a generation of leaders and they
were right for that era and what was
going on.
Fast forward 20,
30 years,
I'm not sure.
And I've actually sat with a group of my
counterpart,
you know,
forties successful and said,
who's the leader?
Who's the voice,
what voice captures what's happening in
african american community.
Now,
to be fair,
it's not monolithic.
African americans,
You know,
like any other guy.
That's why I don't like it,
but it was never modeled that they put.
We had leaders.
Martin luther king was a leader,
although you know,
he,
he wasn't from industry,
he didn't,
you know,
so,
but still he represented just,
he caught and captured the voice of the
community.
I have to honestly say,
and it's something that bothers me.
I don't know who that person is and,
and I'm not so sure that if you asked
him lack people,
nine of them would say,
I'm not sure who that leader is.
Yeah.
And it's so complex because you remember
a couple of years ago when oprah said
the thing about how well we just need
these old racists to die and she was
referencing,
she was referencing some people's
grandmothers and grandfathers and I
remember thinking,
and I have no beef with open,
but I remember hearing that and thinking
this is so dangerous.
It gets back to what we were talking
about earlier about how You just live in
your times and all that.
Like no one wants to look at their
grandparents who live grew up in a
different time of thing.
I had to wait until you just drop dead
so you can't vote anymore with it.
And it
makes me think,
you know,
I had my grandmother taught school for
46 years in broward county,
Florida.
And um,
I remember she said something to me now
and I think the world of my grandmother,
she's still alive,
93 years old,
94.
It just had a birthdaY.
And um,
I remember going down to the university
of miami and I came home and I said,
I think I've met someone and it was,
she assumed it was a white woman because
I'm at a majority institution,
you know,
lily white,
university of miami.
And she said,
son,
I'd rather you bring a man home that,
wow,
now this is someone who I adore and I
think the world of her.
But I had to stop and pause.
It stuck me.
I remember that I'd rather you bring a
manhole than a white woman.
And I had to realize that a lot of folks
hold these racial things and they are
products of their era like,
right.
so when I see,
you know,
an older 90 year old lady or old white
guy who has an harbor,
some racial animus,
I wasn't around then,
I can't really put that in context.
I'm not justifying it,
I'm not saying it's right or wrong,
but what I am saying to your earlier
point is I love my grandmother and if
you tried to attack my grandmother
because she espoused that worldview,
I would attack you because I look at the
totality of her contributions to this
country and her,
her racist tendencies.
I want a product of the era that she
grew up in,
but they are also a very,
very small part of the full woman that I
know.
Yes.
And that's the key part.
Everyone wants to define everything you
said earlier.
You could figure out some thing that you
did when you were 18.
something that I did when I was 26 and
go man,
affordances that matter.
Right?
Exactly.
But that's the point that we're just
pieces of all of this.
Uh,
it's easy to.
And that's,
that's a problem.
we just want to collapse on.
The one thing that someone did that,
by the way unpopular now,
what do you think a martin luther king,
we would think about the identity
politics stuff it.
It's I,
I would like to think,
and by the way I say that because you
read so many versions of what martin
fought.
I've heard people say he was a
republican.
Then I've heard people help he,
he's a womanizer.
He said this,
you just don't know.
I think you can make an interesting
argument that he was a conservative and
endow a.
He doesn't want his children to be
judged by the color of their skin.
That actually sounds a little more like
a conservative idea because that's not
an identity politics idea yet.
Hit a lot of his economic stuff was
veering more towards socialism in a way,
so I think you can argue both,
but I think on balance,
I think he would.
I believe that he would be looking.
He's looking down and saying,
you know,
no system is perfect.
No set of rules is perfect,
but this is a lot better people today
than it was what we inherited back then
is far worse than what you have today,
so why don't we look at the progress
that was made and figure out how we
build on it.
I'd like to think that because his
nature was one of working together,
finding commonality and peaceful
protests,
you know,
people now you know not allowing people
to talk when you disagree with them,
literally shouting them down.
Think about that era when martin luther
king,
we were the minority.
There were clearly,
I mean really in the minority,
literally they could have silenced him
by yelling and shouting him down and
somehow the country allow that voice to,
to and people embraced it because they
listened to it.
Even people who were probably not
inclined to agree with him,
you know,
for that that time,
but by listening,
they said,
oh,
maybe he's done to something,
and it really piqued their heart.
It got to the heart and said,
you know what?
This is probably not the right way to
think about my fellow americans.
It was because they listened,
but if you aren't even being,
if you can't hear,
if you're unwilling to listen.
Martin has to be sad right now.
Yeah.
I was just,
at the moment I was telling me how is
this an dc going all these things and
that's what I felt.
I just felt things had gotten so much
better for everybody.
It doesn't matter.
There isn't racism.
It doesn't mean some people don't like
gay people or any of those things,
but we are.
Laws basically are fair and it's like
where else are they doing it better?
That's right.
Are you looking to move somewhere?
I mean,
the same thing right after even after
the trump election,
you know,
I remembered all of those folks.
If he is elected,
I'm leaving the country.
No,
I'm still here and I check every day.
She's still here.
Right?
All of these folks with rosie and the
name of the group who all thought they
were gonna leave the country.
I'm like,
you're not going anywhere.
Shut up.
I don't want to go too far down the
trump thing unless you want to go there,
but do you think that whatever's
happening with him right now,
and as you said,
as we're taping this today,
manafort was indicted by the fbi.
It sounds like it's not even directly
about the trump campaign,
that it's about some Ukraine stuff
before,
but,
but we'll see where all that plays out.
But as a general rule,
what do you make of what's happened?
Because to me,
what I keep trying to say is if you just
let go of the tweets for a minute,
you let go over the media hysteria.
Basically nothing bad has happened
basically.
Well,
two things.
First of all,
y'all.
I know it's hard to get rid of the.
No,
no.
You've only had eight months of it,
so yeah,
nothing bad could really happen at eight
months.
Anyway.
This is a republic that has been around
for a very long time.
It's going to be around a long time
after him.
So that's the beginning.
The other thing is it goes back to this
media thing.
If You are,
if you continually.
There's a barrage of information.
It says everything this person does is
bad.
At some point you believe it.
Right,
and I think that's a part of it.
He's trying to figure it out.
Could he stay off the tweet a little
bit?
Twitter off?
Yes.
Could he be a little bit more
presidential?
Hell,
he admitted it this weekend when he said
that,
but I'm about to say about Michael
Morton is totally non presidential.
Well knows alert president trump.
Several of those sorts of things have
not been president,
so I'm glad you're acknowledging
it.
Yeah,
he can't though.
Right?
Because that's what got them there.
That's what's got him there and that's
what people forget.
It worked and frankly,
as much as we talk about he's not
reflecting America.
Yes he does.
He,
you know,
43 million americans voted for him.
Forty six for hillary and people don't
factor the sin,
but $3 million.
Hillary won the state of great state of
California by 3 million votes.
people forget that.
So pull those.
That $3,
million person spread was like here for
the record.
I in California voted for Gary Johnson
and judge me however you will see
another judge me however you want,
but I suspect you would do I feel that
of the ideas of gary did.
In fact I did that,
but you know,
we know he wasn't going to win so that's
a whole different conversation.
But I,
but I,
I'm in California.
It didn't matter which way.
Right.
That's like me in Washington dc for the
democratic candidate was when full stop.
Right?
Yeah.
And again that gets back to the issue is
country is just,
you're,
you're in one camp or the other and it
is when you think 46 and 43 million
people we're calling,
we really divided.
I mean I just don't even know where the
center is anymore.
That's,
that's troubling.
So to me,
the center basically is somewhat
economically conservative in that you
earn your money,
you should keep it.
And I also always argued that's the best
way.
If you hate trump,
the best way to limit government is to
stop giving it so much money and power
because sometime you know what?
You might get bernie and he can use a
lot of power that you like,
but then sometimes you're gonna get a
guy you don't like,
so let's just stop giving them so much
power,
but in a weird way.
Does This all show that our system is
working properly?
Well,
that's.
You know,
you,
you mentioned it earlier.
This is not a perfect system,
but I don't.
There's no other place in the world.
I'd rather be.
I thank god every day when I wake up
and,
and so you know that I'm here and it
because we could have all been born
somewhere else and this could have been
a really bad situation.
It's not a perfect union,
but we're working towards it and that's
the optimism,
but it's only if we have conversations
like this,
the two of us,
this doesn't appear on mainstream
television by the way.
That's the thing that I got to figure
out how to get you.
Hey,
let me be your age,
but we have to get.
I believe you could do it.
I don't even know that I want it,
but I believe that really could because
this voice is what's missing.
You're either msnbc or fox news,
you're rachel or your hannity and that
by the way,
doesn't get us any closer to fixing this
because people then divide out.
That's What we've got to do because
rational people can.
I think reasonable people can come to
some conclusions that this is good for
all of us.
You know,
relating this to sort of where we
started as you're saying this,
I'm thinking,
you know,
there's something interesting here.
If this identity politics stuff wins the
day and they start taking more monuments
and we start judging Thomas Jefferson
and the rest of the founders on the
morals of today.
It's not just that we'll remove them,
but we'll actually all of good ideas,
all of their good ideas will have to go
away.
They won't even if you're like a lot of
those good ideas,
you know what I mean?
Like they won't just magically keep some
of the ideas what you're going to
actually remove all of those ideas and
then what are we left with and it ain't
pretty right and,
and it's not America that that's the
reality.
It's not America.
And that's something that we've all got
to come to grips with is that this is
not a good direction.
The trajectory is all wrong.
I'm pleased to say,
and all of us in the market,
so performing the financially you'll do
well,
but by the way,
if you don't have any money,
you're not participating in the markets
anyway.
Right?
So people like the two of us,
we're going to do fine.
Our families and significant others and
stakeholders are going to do fine.
It's the rest of these folks who are
being left out and they unfortunately
are buying into this narrative that
America is bad and somehow the magic fix
is to tax the wealthy.
like where does that end?
Like who.
And so is the appeal of that just
because it takes,
it's sort of lazy thinking,
you know what I mean?
Like,
it just doesn't take much to be like,
I want what somebody else has.
Like,
it's kind of an easy answer.
like I don't have somebody all got.
They should gIve me some of that.
Like you don't have to think that hard.
Relax.
You have to think harder to understand
why you shouldn't or don't deserve
someone else's money.
Let's see.
I don't,
I,
and why?
Maybe.
But it's also equally lazy to think if I
were a zoo,
you know,
I'm a millionaire,
I wouldn't want to give more of my money
to someone else if I earned it.
Even if I bought a freaking lottery
ticket,
uh,
you know,
just basic.
Take some person who's from a fragile
community and who's got limited
resources and you say to them,
you won the lottery tomorrow.
You want $2,000,000,
5 million of it goes to the federal
government in your state.
How does that make you feel?
Bad.
That's lazy.
I mean,
you don't have a lot to say.
That's not a good result,
right?
Yeah.
So I don't know why this is,
I don't know that it's easy.
I think it's,
we have just pounded into people's heads
that taking that the rich people are
bad.
you're vilified for going to work
everyday and making some good decisions
and some luck and some god and some
fate.
All of that into totality.
You're bad for having done well and the
media plays it consistent.
They,
you belIeve it.
You believe it.
What do you think is the right amount of
government for us to have?
Um,
as much as we need.
I know that's not a great answer,
but I would literally,
I'm sort of,
I'm not sort of,
I'm very conservative in that respect.
I don't think you can have no government
[inaudible] then you have anarchy.
We need.
So you don't want mad max,
right?
I don't want that.
I mean if my house burns down,
I want to police department to show up.
I don't wanna have to rely on my three
neighbors with buckets to come at a fire
department to show up.
So I think government,
the infrastructure is important of any
society that will endure.
I do think that we've gotten too far
though,
when you have just huge bureaucracy and
departments designed to
solve problems that frankly will solve
themselves amongst people.
Yeah,
but we become completely dependent on
it.
Is there any way to scale it back?
That's one of the questions that I try
to ask a lot of my more libertarian
guests like it seems like this,
this thing has gotten so big and when
you factor it in with,
you know,
handouts and all of this stuff that if
you were ever to take it back,
a lot of people think,
well,
you just be screwing over all the poor
people that.
Then I have some people who come on and
say,
no,
you just cut it tomorrow and we see what
happens.
We'll charities come in.
We'll churches and synagogues and
mosques and all that.
Well,
they pick up the slack,
you know,
will.
If you cut the funding until planned
parenthood would barbara streisand and
rosie and the rest of them suddenly put
some of their money towards that.
I tend to think the answer is yes,
I do.
How do you,
how do you get that point across to
people?
Well,
they're not going to do it unless forced
to do it,
so I think so that's something to be
said for.
Just stop.
I mean,
what we saw puerto rico's a classic
example.
We're all forced,
you know,
worried about what's happening in puerto
rico,
but this didn't start with a hurricane.
Puerto rico was a disaster.
I mean when I read something,
I was down there last year and they said
70 or so percent of the population work
for the government like that has gotten
out of control and the only way you fix
that,
you can't come in and say,
hey guys,
50 percent of you all should give up
your government jobs for us to get this
right.
No,
you're just gonna have to kind of just
have to be.
You just have to.
And that's the.
Frankly,
that's the opportunity and I want to be
careful here because I don't want,
I didn't,
I'm not a trump sarah got or anything
else,
but that's the opportunity for someone
like him.
I think we have just elected our first
independent president.
I think it's the first time that America
has had someone who says what they think
for good or bad,
but and who is prepared to be unpopular
because to make these sorts of decisions
you got to be unpopular and okay with
that.
So was that his best line during the
campaign?
When he said basically to the black
community,
he was like,
what do you got to lose?
Do you think?
It was an actual.
It ended up being a good line because it
sounded off when I heard it.
And then I've talked to a lot of people
and they kind of were like,
yeah,
all these democratic run cities,
chicago,
atlanta,
ferguson.
That's where it's the worst.
So it was funny.
I remembered,
I knew,
I know where I was at that moment when
that happened and I was with a group of
my friends and one of my friends who is
as liberal as they come,
I've never sent me.
He drips and he said to me,
it was this moment like when you eat
something that's bitter at first,
and then you're like,
oh,
that tastes good.
Ultimately.
Yeah.
And he said he's onto something and that
was when I knew that actually resonated.
I didn't feel good at first.
I mean I got it checked because it was a
little dismissive and frankly the
african american community is still
enjoying the fact that we elected our
first african american president and
frankly so are a lot of non african
americans,
right?
It was a big deal.
So they felt like it was a shot at
obama.
That's,
that was the issue.
If you had taken obama out of the
equation,
having been the president,
it was a totally reasonable statement to
say ever the guy was before.
He didn't meaningfully change your life.
I am prepared to do what do you have to
lose?
So I think you just,
if you took obama out of it and the
pride associated with him being a,
you know,
a first,
um,
I think it was totally logical.
Ironically,
I think you can make a great argument
that the president himself,
whether it's obama or trump or anybody
else,
shouldn't have that much power over your
life.
Well,
that,
that would be my greater solutIon here.
That's my attitude.
People say,
well,
you know,
I wouldn't want to have lunch with
Donald Trump.
I said,
and you're,
oh,
that's easy.
I want my president to do two things.
Literally I have sort of drawn it down
to this national security and economic
security.
I want the economy economy to be strong
globally.
I want them on it and then I want to
make sure that the homeland is secure in
the context of a global kind of his,
so it's not just domestic,
but you got to do some things are
nationally to protect your homeland.
Those two things.
I don't care what the president thinks
about much of anything because he's a
man just like I am and you are,
so he'll have an opinion about x and
that's good for him.
Their supreme court does.
Congress has all of that stuff,
but I just want them to do two things.
Economic security and what I'll call
homeland,
but security,
national security.
Is it funny to you how everybody's sort
of flipped their opinions on almost
everything these days?
Because as you're saying that,
I'm thinking if we just go back 20
minutes when we were talking about daca,
it's like,
well suddenly democrats,
because they didn't like what trump was
doing.
We're fighting for states' rights and
it's like,
yeah,
I want you guys to fight rights all the
time.
could then I'll start voting with you
again.
We'll look at the obamacare,
the new proposed a affordable health
care act.
By that,
you know,
the idea is black granite to the states.
I thought that's what we all want,
right?
It's and I was surprised to see some
states.
Actually,
no,
we don't want it.
What do you mean you don't want it?
The ability of mr or ms.gov
to manage and take care of your
citizenry with your dollars without the
intervention of some people in
Washington dc who know nothing about
what happens in spokane,
Washington.
You don't want man.
To me that's like the most like perfect
example of how screwed up our system is
that a governor who is executor of the
estate would be like,
no,
no.
The thing that I'm supposed to do.
You do,
let's send it over there.
That way I'm free in the clear.
That's like the worst.
That's why people hate politicians.
That's why people hate the media.
It's like holding it.
I want.
I live in California,
which they're probably going to execute,
but in five years for a little freedom
libertarian,
and believe me,
if they,
if they succeed from the unit,
I really can I move in with you.
I'll be in Missouri,
but that the Iowa,
that's what I do.
But.
But that point basically of everything's
being flipped right now.
Like everyone's kind of all over the
place.
It's actually cool.
I mean that's all I know.
So many people
are depressed about it,
but what I've been trying to say is
there's opportunity here.
It doesn't mean it's going to be bad.
It doesn't mean it's going to be good,
but let's get in there and fight for
what you believe.
Even if you believe in the stuff that I
abhor.
Right?
Right.
But they're lazy.
I mean that you use the right word.
People are lazy.
This is actually fascinating to watch.
Now I want to separate it.
Earlier I said,
you know,
I'm nervous about where this is going.
That's true.
I'm hopeful.
I'm not necessarily optimistic and
there's a difference,
right?
yeah.
But I do enjoy watching the process,
the sausage making.
I do like to see that ultimately,
you know,
if you go back and look at some of the,
at least the reports of the early
founding fathers,
it was ugly.
They hated each other.
It was divided like nothing you've ever
seen and all of the what we refer to as
going on in congress right now.
Hell,
it happened back then to this might be
the american experience.
Right.
And you were just in time.
What we do is we put a painting,
we tell a story around it and it looks
so wonderful and dramatic,
but the reality is it's ugly.
You know,
operating in this sort of a government,
this,
this model of,
of,
of governing is ugly and it's got to be
ugly or I mean,
what's the option?
I mean,
I think that's what people don't
understand is like if anything's going
to work,
it kind of has to be ugly.
That mean the sausage factory there.
I think nobody wants to see how it gets
made,
but you don't like it.
No.
Shit like it.
While I was,
I was reading the other day,
I know you've seen it,
the comments,
um,
vayner is now talking about what
happened,
you know,
god suddenly the man's curse of his
marines and the idea that,
you know,
some way literally he said got either
pulled a gun or a knife on him or
something.
One of his fellow members of congress
and uh,
iT's just fascinated.
Literally he's had an and but that's.
And that's within the party.
So the idea that somehow the tension is,
is bad,
maybe not so much.
Yeah.
It's also funny because like,
you know,
you'll always hear all the,
all these media people and politicians
and be like,
house of cards is the most realistic
show ever.
And it's like,
well there's an awful lot of murder and
drug use and evil backdoor deals and
you're just,
you guys are all kind of telling us that
are all showing it to us.
All right,
well we could go a rabbit hole on that
one.
So let's,
let's shift to your future.
Because you mentioned,
you mentioned earlier,
so you are leaving the organization that
basically then the next month.
Right,
and where are you going?
What are you doing going to run an
organization called the society for
human resource management?
Sure,
and it's the world's largest association
dedicated to human resources,
so trade association for the profession
of human resources professionals and you
know,
so some have said,
wow,
that's kind of out there.
Will know it isn't for for a couple of
reasons.
First of all,
I've been in higher ed for the last
seven and a half years.
If you ask nine out of 10 college
students,
why did you go to college?
Is to get a good job period.
So it's a very natural kind of thing.
There's no point of going if this
doesn't turn into some way to provide.
The other thing though is it's a natural
sort of evolution in my career.
I now understand higher ed.
Actually.
I think I have a really good
understanding of all of the education.
So pk through 16,
we've now got a connected.
There's not an article that comes out.
We're employers say the system is not
giving me what I want.
The students who are graduating don't
have the skills that we need and so
they're frustrated because I'm paying
taxes to pay for this system education
system and the what comes out on the
other end.
The assembly line model is really bad.
I paid for all of this and at the end of
the car I don't like it.
So I think this gives me an opportunitY
to take what I've done for the last
seven and a half years and now take,
get industry,
bring the two together and say let's
figure out how to make this system work.
We're spending a lot of money as a
country on education and to what end.
So what are some of the ways you could
shift education?
I mean,
I think the basic premises of get people
to listen and get people to really
understand what they believe in,
but is there something that's like a
little more concrete that you're going
to go in and be like,
guys,
let's.
This is what we got to change.
Yeah.
You know,
you know the,
the current administration is talking a
lot about apprenticeships.
For example,
the end gain can't be everyone goes to
four year college and I think we went
that way for too long and that didn't
work.
So the idea is to figure out
credentialing,
to figure out what are the specific
skills that one needs to go into the
21st century economy industry has to
tell us that since they are ultimately
the consumer of this education product,
and then we got to go back and say,
okay,
now you've got to tweak your system.
I know you all don't like being
vocations,
vocational schools and you want to teach
people how to think and solve the
world's problems,
but the vast majority of the folks who
come through your system are doing what
they're trying to get a job.
So that's what we're going to do.
Concretely.
Bringing those education and industry
together and say,
let's figure this out.
We've got to rethink and talking about
disruption.
I predict that higher education in
particular is going to be disrupted in a
way as a,
as a business,
as a sector,
like nothing you've ever seen.
The pieces are all there for that right
now because we see the schools that a
lot of the schools that have gone down
the sjw route are really struggling.
Mizzou is majorly struggling and
enrollment.
We know evergreen state struggling.
I mean,
well,
you have another problem.
America and americans just had fewer
babies.
The reality is we,
we,
uh,
we've seen there are fewer students
graduating high school this year than
last year and the year before.
So what we're seeing is a problem.
You're just not going to have the same
number of bodies to come into that
traditional college environment that we
created with dorms and everything else.
So now we are nontraditional student has
to be our traditional students.
That's got to be a little ironic for you
in a way.
You come from the higher ed thing,
you care so much about it and yet you
can also acknowledge that a certain
amount of people just because of the
reality of economics,
don't necessarily need all of that
education that you know that's right,
and it's going to be lifelong,
you know,
it's the idea that we came out of the
generation where you get your education,
your bachelors,
your masters or doctorate,
what have you get,
and then you go into the workplace and
do it for 30 years and you retire and
now because the economy is changing so
much,
every five to seven years,
industries go away that we were taught
to participate in.
They go away.
And so that's.
I'm so excited about that.
Finally,
you know,
sort of related to that America is
browning and graying at once.
So underlying all of this is we've got
to figure out how to get the system to
appreciate a very different America.
It's not black and white anymore.
It's brown,
it's yellow,
it's everything.
And how these workers,
as they come out of college or whatever
their educational backgrounds are when
they come into the workplace,
how do we grow our economy?
Uh,
and we've got to use people to do it
right.
And that's what I'm excited about,
sherman and higher education and just
trying to figure out how to tie that all
together.
Yeah.
Well,
I gotta tell you,
man,
I,
I thoroughly enjoyed this.
I'm not surprised because as I said,
I saw you once and I was like,
this guy's going to do it.
But I think the real beauty of this is
that you're not just saying this stuff,
you're actually out there doing it.
And I believe that that's right.
I don't believe,
you know,
this isn't about my desire to run for
office or to get a job.
Um,
I really believe this.
This is something that it keeps me up at
night.
How can people like the two of us
changed the narrative.
Thank you.
Thank you for.
I feel like I gotta I gotta give you one
more here.
That'll all right.
What would you say,
what would you say that.
Well,
thank you.
But what would you say then to the to
the people,
whether they're college students right
now or whether they're middle aged,
whatever it is that want to get in the
fight,
but are afraid because of all the
silencing factors.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Know two things.
First of all,
you need courage.
You've got to intestinal courage.
You got to just go down and decide this
is the,
this is where I want to go.
And by the way,
that means transferring schools.
If that means changing the people you
spend time around because you know it
can be debilitating in some ways,
then do it.
I mean,
it's just the only way to do it.
The other thing is I would encourage all
americans.
We've got to listen more.
The most frustrating thing to me now is
we're so busy talking and frankly
talking over others that we just won't
pause and listen.
That's the beginning of changing the
narrative because as you're listening,
you're going to one,
the other person will respect you.
Now because you've listened to them,
and in the process you actually might
learn something.
You might say,
you know,
the world is a little different than I
perceived it to be because I got it from
someone else's perspective.
That's the beauty of diversity by the
way.
It's not just gender and race and
national origin.
It's diverse perspectives.
How another person sees the world.
If we can get those two things now,
first of all,
listen,
But then courage.
It takes a lot frankly for me to be
right here,
the best thing in the world.
If I aspire to be a congressman and a
member of the cbc and dah,
dah,
there's a narrative that I'm supposed to
follow and you've got to decide that,
that that doesn't matter.
What's more important is that the
american story,
100 years from now is,
is a much better story because I was
here.
I love it.
That's
a closing statement and for more on
johnny,
you guys can follow him on the twitter
machine at johnny c dot taylor jr.